take how are you I'm doing well how are
you Coenen I'm doing very well I'm
disturbed by the lack of any kind of
furniture or decoration behind you
there's nothing there's nothing here oh
you went all out yeah that's my chimney
my bedroom chimney that we had to
explain to our kids that Santa because
they were worried about what chimney
sano is gonna come down and and we
explained that Santa won't be coming
down that chimney hopefully you know
what right that's good that's good and
your are 38 and 40 is that right correct
today birthday they're still excited
about Santa
now you're how old three years old right
three and a half we and a half three and
a half and I just turned 39 Conan that's
right you just celebrated a birthday
happy birthday right here in captivity
well we don't call it captivity we call
it soft quarantine II
sure you know what I love our awkward
pauses are even more delicious in its
format
do you feel like you are mentally
prepared mentally in good shape for this
quarantine they we're all in right now I
think some people are better prepared
than others
tell me take how are you in this
situation you know I obviously have not
been through this ever before as we know
it but I have I don't know if you're
aware but I've had some medical issues
over the years I am weary yes yes I've
actually been I think hospitalized six
or seven times in the past seven years
and when I'm feeling better I work a lot
I travel around and many times during my
healing processes and work I've thought
I would love to be home with my family I
would give anything to be home with my
family and I was looking at this as
being quarantined and then about a week
ago
it dawned on me that maybe I could shift
things in my brain and just act like I
chose this time off right and it has
helped me and I know again I've never
been through this so maybe tomorrow
there will be a you know murder-suicide
going on but I Stephanie and I give each
other a couple hours a day alone and
that's very helpful that's key you have
to have some separation because I know
you guys are a great couple you began
been together many years now what eight
years now seven I appreciate you keeping
track of it all I think about every
morning little I have a little abacus
next to my bed and I slide a bead over
and it's dedicated your relationship the
staff thank you so you've only slid the
beat over seven times now yeah you got
ahead of yourself I got ahead it just
felt like you guys were together eight
seems like yeah
seven beats but yeah that's the thing is
that a lot of couples right now are
going through a tough time because
they're in close quarters that's why I
do everything I can to just go into
another room I can tell when my wife has
had it with me you think it's important
to not wait until you're driving each
other insane and take the two just take
two hours yes the two hours really
really really is making such a
difference and then we miss each other
and we're not we're spending four hours
apart a day
essentially it's Mike and I we've
switched that around which is where own
we decided to only be together for one
hour and be separate the rest of the
time and my wife has never had art no
she's delighted she says this is the
just the exact amount of Koenen that
anyone should have in their life no more
so do your kids find you amusing I mean
I can entertain them about 10 percent of
the time and I'm 90 percent of the time
it's contempt and loathing just think
it's a fine mix you want to well I think
you know with certain audiences that's
what I I've gotten as well for years
some people don't recognize what I do as
comedy right right
sometimes it helps just to tell them by
the way this is comedy yeah well I have
somebody announced that before each show
someone says oh and by the way what
you're about to experience is comedy
right if anyone starts to get up to
leave in a huff we have somebody come
over the loudspeaker to let people know
don't worry she's getting to a punchline
[Laughter]